and if you look at the track record of
vladimir putin's regime over the past
two decades that has been empowering our
country we'll see a long and growing
list
of political opponents independent
journalists anti-corruption activists
who have met with similar fate poisoning
has been a favored method uh
long has been a favorite method backs in
soviet days of uh russian security
services he doesn't have to be poisoning
all the time
five and a half years ago uh russian
opposition leader and former deputy
prime minister boris nemtsov
was literally gunned down in front of
the crowning walls
and to this day the russian government
at the highest levels continues to
shield and protect the organizers and
masterminds of that assassination again
for the reason i think that's obvious
for everybody
so the first minute i heard of what uh
happened to alexander viney had
absolutely no doubt that this was a
deliberate
politically motivated attack against
someone who today is the most effective
the most prominent
frankly the most dangerous political
opponent of the putin regime
uh as you know many opponents of the
criminal has suffered this fate
both on russian soil and abroad
including in your own country in the
united kingdom have the dubious
distinction of having
experienced this twice it's long been a
favorite method above all because it
gives them
or so they think plausible deniability
because every every time something like
this happens
you hear these statements from kremlin
spokespeople that oh we had nothing to
do with this how can you prove it blah
blah blah
it's exactly the same that we are
starting to hear again today i think
it's very important to finally start
calling a spade in spade
and call this for what it is again it's
a politically motivated attack
against the main russian opposition
leader that was conducted
by the means of a russian
government-made novichok
organophosphorus nerve agent it's not
something you can go and buy in a
pharmacy
it is a highly controlled substance and
only the state has access to it